a newly renovated senior center will be  available for seniors in the valley the  expansion of the martin luther king  center will help seniors  interact with their friends socialize  it's really an opportunity  to provide important information about  health screenings that are needed  as well as medical insurance i'm  elated everything they asked for they  got it with the addition of a surprise  and so  the movie tv room is a big surprise but  you know i think they're going to be so  happy and  they can't wait to get in the building  so governor scissor like hello  my seniors are ready to get in their  building commissioner weekly adding the  center will make sure to protect the  vulnerable sector when they open up  their doors